[Music]
from the studio who won't release the
Schneider cut and this guy I'm sorry
you have the most beautiful feet comes a
period piece about psychological and
social decay with the bare minimum of
Batman it took to get the movie made
there look with the pearls and
everything happy
Joker prepare for a film the media set
was too dangerous for you to see which
made audiences way more excited than
regular marketing ever could have
cruising its way to a billion dollars on
a 55 million budget because it got hype
like a cinematic fear toxin that that
would turn you into the Joker even
though it ended up being a mumblecore
Scorsese brief about the world's saddest
clown hey I wish movies turned you into
the protagonist I've been watching
Ironman for 12 years and I'm still a
[ __ ] journey to 1980s Gotham where the
garbage is high the clown rental
business is booming and everything is
yellow from the urban squalor a joker
will rise in Arthur flak and if Marvel
is known for making their heroes get
ripped DC will one-up them by making
their Star get ribs he's a loner who
deserves all your sympathy for being
poor and mentally ill but earns all of
your contempt for being a viral video
star and wannabe comedian
he's got the faded hoodie and everything
dude looks like he's about to ask you to
do his podcast go back to the oven Mikey
Pisa
some Joker's are in it for the ego some
just want to watch the world burn now
this version is here to teach you a
lesson you should show more compassion
for the mentally ill or they'll snap and
kill you hey wait a minute
but this joker has a few unique tricks
up his sleeve
like the superhuman capacity to pay the
elderly sleep in a refrigerator and
instead of writing damaged on his
forehead just damage his forehead yikes
you better fight Batman quick before he
turns 12 and overpowers him experience a
film with one of the all-time great
joaquin phoenix gangly loner
performances and one of the let's say
third most uncomfortable joaquin phoenix
interviews i have a large frog in my
hair no
something's calling out of my scalp that
shows off one of the greatest actors of
our generations incredible range from
laughing normally to laughing because of
a medical condition - laughing
maniacally - cry laughing - every laugh
in between hey you know you'd think of
film that was 70 percent laughing and
dancing would be more Abid but the other
30% is getting the crap kicked out of
him
Wow do you feel some type of way about
society this movie does and the message
is going to be in closer and bold just
in case you missed it because the true
villains of Joker are uncaring
billionaires misogynist Wall Street
jerks lack of government funding the
city's cut funding across the board
Social Services is part of that and easy
access to guns you got to protect
yourself out there so wait
it wasn't an in selling cry or an anti
sjw screed how is it possible that every
heartache about this movie was wrong
including the directors so enjoy a joker
movie that's such a thoughtful
challenging comic-book movie
it almost qualifies as a movie movie
with a take on the iconic character that
perfectly fits our current day and age
that isn't fun like the 60s innocent
like the 80s grim like the 2000s or
embarrassing like the 2010 but exists
less as a story than a piece of content
- hysterically react to that immediately
forget until the next outrage comes
along everybody just yells and screams
of each other I'm so sick of the society
it makes me so mad I'm gonna lose it and
do Joker stuff mom get in the bath
starring mo / don't trust a see an
apartment AP because she's imaginary you
are not the father
Lil Wayne don't you go round and round
two rear oh I heard you paint faces hey
Arthur are we cool and stairs
[Music]
dance dance revelution these finance
guys know all the words to send in the
clowns bottle a night Sondheim sessions
with the boys when you give me my Oscar
can you introduce me as Joker let me see
you shake your tailfeather Jack
Skellington eating jello would
technically be cannibalism this is just
God real juicy but to you yeah